this podcast is brought to you by
bespoke posts
box of awesome everything you can
imagine doing
in the vicinity of our sun for example
like having
various objects in orbit around it
essentially you know for billions of
years you could do that with a black
hole as well
just because the black hole is there
doesn't mean that it's some big vacuum
cleaner
that sucks things in
[Music]
pete i know you know a little bit about
black holes i do because
on what if every eighth third video
every third video yeah we do a lot of
black hole videos here but that speaks
to
the fact that tons of people are
fascinated with black holes
fast it's a fascinating subject because
most people know nothing about them
other than they're one black then
they're a black hole that sucks stuff
into them
and as we'll find out in today's show
there's going to be some myths and
misconceptions about black holes
that will be answered because a lot of
the things we think we do know
are starting to change but that's why
we have guests like physics professors
on the show to be able to help us
sort out things like what if our solar
system orbited a black hole
today we're going to be joined by usc
professor of physics
clifford johnson but first some good
news for the what if discussed
community well that's right uh this fall
as you get back into the swing of things
bespoke post has a brand new seasonal
box of awesome collection for guys
guaranteed to upgrade your life this
month i got the aged box and that's a
kit that lets me
barrel age my spirits at home and when i
say spirits i mean lickers
which lifts your spirit it's absurd
sometimes it does i'm pretty excited
about i'm
aging some gin right now and you age it
for 10 days and today is uh
day 10 so i'll let you know how it goes
my box of awesome
yeah a couple of things i was torn
between the gadget
thing that you know i live in a condo so
anything that can sort of check the
boxes on a million different tool
applications is great but
ultimately the travel bag is super cool
because i'm somebody who likes to
if i'm going away for like 10 days or
100 days i want to carry on and that's
it
i was thinking of that one but i haven't
been traveling anywhere lately thanks to
also true yeah whether it's gear to
upgrade your autumn craft beers or cozy
threads for when the temperature dips
bespoke posts only sends guys the best
stuff
every month no matter what you're into
box of awesome has you covered from
style and grooming goods to bar wear
cooking tools and outdoor gear box of
awesome has collections for every part
of your life to get started
take the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
like i said
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time so
no real commitment each box costs only
45 bucks but has over 70 bucks worth of
gear inside
i've got a bunch of extra money these
days from uh not spending cash on gas or
transit so 45 bucks seems quite
reasonable especially when you get
double the value
yeah yeah you get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com
and enter the code what if at checkout
that's box of awesome dot com
code what if all one word for 20 off
your first box
giddyup so let's get started and again
like we talked about off the top black
holes you and i
uh superficial knowledge at best again
that's why
uh we'd like to have experts on the show
to help us understand in this case
what if our solar system orbited a black
hole
i don't really know the answer you get
sucked in pretty sure you don't know the
answer
so we're joined by again professor of
physics from the university of southern
california clifford johnson
hi great to be here uh professor
thanks for joining us uh it sounds like
a simple question to start but
it we might as well go there what is a
black hole
well that is something that does come
into
various uh of these fields in a way
because
we think about the nature of space and
time
and a black hole is fundamentally
something very very
fundamentally different about space and
time that we had thought
that that had been thought of until you
know the last um
uh uh century of of work in great detail
and what it is we we understand in
general
is simply a region of space where
for whatever reason the gravitational
pull is
so strong that not even light
can escape from it in the sense that you
know if we wanted to get off this body
here
earth we we send we send rockets
away uh into space and we do that by
getting up to a certain speed a certain
escape velocity
which allows you to escape escape the
gravitational pull
and uh for reasons that we we could go
into
but but let's not for now uh there's a
there's a fastest
possible speed that you can do in this
universe it's the speed of light
so if you had a body that was so uh
gravitationally strong that the escape
speed was faster than the speed of light
then nothing uh would be able to escape
from it
and that's what a black hole is there's
there's various uh
levels of black hole as i understand
it's kind of like the wendy's
drive-through there's your regular black
hole
and there's a super massive black hole a
medium a triple a double
what's the difference between a regular
and a super massive black hole
well one of the amazing things about
black holes is that they
are uh by some definitions
very very complicated objects and by
other definitions they are
the simplest objects in the universe
that we've ever encountered in in
physics
and so in some ways the only difference
between
those different kinds of black holes
that you talk about is how big they are
and so you have black holes that
are say have roughly a few times the
mass of our sun
because they come from stars that have
in some sense died they've gone to a new
phase of existence where they're no
longer glowing like stars and they
collapse and they form this
compact object and so they have a mass
that is essentially
related to the stuff that collapsed um
but then you have regions of space uh
for example at the core
of most galaxies where there are black
holes
that are huge hundreds of millions of
times the mass
of a typical star and in some sense
they're very closely related
to those smaller kinds of black holes
and they're also intermediate mass
black holes and some of us speculate
that there may also be microscopic black
holes
uh as a possibility in nature as well
all shapes and sizes yes a kid's meal um
one of this i guess more recently it's
being called a misconception or a myth
about black holes i know
for the most part in in the sci-fi world
you know it was always portrayed that
you get sucked into a black hole
basically if you're
you know in too close proximity to a
black hole that was it you couldn't
you couldn't help but get sucked in
that's not exactly true
is it exactly right again you should
think of
a black hole as uh in many of its
properties it's very similar to any
big blob of matter that you can have uh
if you're if you're far away enough uh
from it
and so everything you can imagine doing
in the vicinity of our sun
for example like having various objects
in orbit around it essentially you know
for billions of years
you can do that with a black hole as
well just because the black hole is
there doesn't mean that it's some big
vacuum cleaner that um that sucks
things in uh which is you know often
portrayed that way and makes it feel
like some kind of uh
some kind of intentional uh behemoth
um no they're just gravitating objects
like anything else
and so you can you can you can uh
you can be near a black hole for an
arbitrarily long time
the issue then is what happens if you
get to
that point of closest approach whereby
you then didn't have enough uh engine
power
to uh to escape or even if you had all
the engine power in the world
you couldn't get faster than the speed
of light to get away and that's called
crossing the event horizon
and there is a point of closest approach
which you then wouldn't be able to
uh at least classically uh and i could
explain what that means
um uh escape uh but if you're
if you're if you're not within the event
horizon in principle
you can you can you can approach and and
move away and it doesn't suck you in
well i guess the big what if for today
is uh
what if uh of our solar system orbited a
black hole is it possible
i think i think from what you're saying
it is possible for a planet or a solar
system
to orbit a black hole but is it also
possible for them to
orbit a black hole and sustain life
i would say my guess is probably yes
uh and i can imagine a number of
different scenarios
uh where that could where that could
come about so
for example uh well
let's first dispense with the issue of
whether we think there may be
other forms of life on other planets
let's say that's not
um not you know beyond the uh
the realm of possibility and you've
probably discussed that in other uh
shows so let's say that there are uh
other stars for which there are other
uh other maybe earth-like or maybe not
earth-like but they have
uh life now it might be that that star
uh may have been part of a binary system
for example
whether you have a double star two stars
orbiting each other and then there are
planets orbiting
that system you can imagine that sort of
thing and maybe one of those
uh became a black hole um
it might have been that it it it
happened with some sort of cataclysmic
explosion as often happens called the
supernova explosion a type 2 supernova
explosion
that may well have obliterated all the
life uh nearby
but let's say let's let's say it didn't
um
then you could you could that could
actually be a rather unusual from our
perspective
but a a home for uh for
that form of life or another possibility
is that you have some star faring
species
that intentionally seeks out a black
hole
and decides to um settle around it they
either build
an object which orbits it or they they
they occupy some planetary matter
that is orbiting that that black hole
and that becomes their star system it
turns out you can actually
mine black holes for energy in a certain
kind of way
and they would be among the most
efficient sources of energy
if you could do the kind of engineering
you would need to to exploit it
so maybe there are super advanced
civilizations that are
living around black holes sorry i was
going to say that literally sounds like
peter's wearing a t-shirt that says
that's a story for another what if
mining black holes for
energy is exactly a story for another
one if that is so cool and not something
i think we've
we've even heard about here but we will
explore it
lots of mysteries around black holes and
a lot of misconceptions about black
holes
so thank you professor johnson for
helping us
clear some of those up uh we're gonna
we're gonna have a longer conversation
with prevents
professor johnson on the other side
before we do where's the best place for
people to follow your work
oh gosh um well uh i would say
they could probably uh either find me
through my blog or through
uh twitter or facebook or instagram um
it's probably best just to google me i
my handle on those things is usually
something called asymptoticia but
telling you to spell that uh
it's easier if you just google my name
and physics and you'll find me
and a nice compact way is to is to look
at a
graphic non-fiction book i wrote and
drew a couple of years ago called the
dialogues
where actually i talk about some of
these issues great stuff professor
johnson
uh not surprising obviously we always
get to learn
cool stuff here on what if discussed
that's what we're here for um
if you would ask me prior do black holes
suck things in
like a vacuum cleaner as he so
eloquently put it i would have said yes
yeah that's what we've learned that's
what we've seen in movies and today's
ten episodes of star trek
based on it yeah but as it turns out
that
mass that incredible mass actually just
creates gravity some people will say
tomato tomato but i think it's a good
clarification what did you learn
i learned that you can i was really
impressed that you could
mine a black hole that sounds i mean i
haven't learned more
enough about that because i want to ask
him that sort of stuff on the other side
so
uh we will continue our discussion with
professor johnson on the extended
audio version of the podcast so uh if
you would like to join us for more just
click on the link below if you're
already listening on the
audio podcast there's nothing for you to
click just stay with us
we'll be back with more professor
johnson otherwise
thanks everyone for joining us on what
if discussed